jackie robinson's story and breaking the
color barrier in baseball is known
around the world
but to fully understand the black
movement in hockey the story begins with
herb carnegie he should have been in the
national hockey league before me he had
all the skills and all the talent you
know he had went to
two training camps i believe with
toronto and the new york rangers you
know was one of the better players there
but unfortunately he just they just
didn't chose him but he had all the
skills and talent you know to to be an
nhler i learned a lot from her talking
to him and working in some of his
programs
in the 1940s
carnegie was a three-time mvp in the
quebec league but blatant racism kept
him out of the nhl unfortunately
carnegie never played in the all-white
nhl but in 1958 one man had the mental
fortitude and the skill to break the nhl
colored barrier when william reese
stepped onto the ice at the montreal
forum playing for the boston bruins
history was made i had butterflies i was
a bit nervous but then the first shift
and i just settled down and played my
game and it was a great feeling we beat
him three nothing and uh what a feeling
it was i really didn't realize that i'd
broke the color barrier or open the
doors for not only
other black players and players of color
until i read it in the paper the next
day but it wasn't until 16 years later
that mike marston was drafted by the
washington capitals
but progress has been slow
as evidenced by recent racially
motivated events the nhl has made a
concerted effort to bring more diversity
into the game and a major step was
appointing william their ambassador of
diversity in 1996. it's a nice feeling
to know that i've made a
difference in a lot of boys and girls
lives over the years that i've been with
the nhl just telling them to set goals
for yourselves
believe in yourself and don't let
anybody tell you you can't attain your
goal if you set your mind on doing
something then go for it